hey Leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen Video ich
hoffe natürlich euch geht es gut ich
sehe irgendwie so ein bisschen aus wie
so ein kleiner Schulung heute ne ich
muss sagen ob die heutige Video Idee bzw
den Inhalt dieses Videos bin ich über
Umwege bekommen ich wollte nämlich auch
mal verloren gegangene Pakete ersteigern
da habe ich mich auch eingetragen in so
einer Auktion die ist jetzt irgendwann
Ende Januar da kann man halt so Hermes
Pakete die irgendwie nicht zugestellt
wurden und so ersteigern fand ich sehr
interessant und da werde ich auf jeden
Fall mitmachen ich habe dann allerdings
eine Seite gefunden die nennt sich
verlorene pakete.de ja wir schauen uns
gleich noch direkt mal an und um diese
Seite wird es heute gehen das Video
zieht sich ein bisschen länger also ich
habe ungefähr schon vor drei Wochen oder
so angefangen mich mit der Seite zu
beschäftigen und ja das ganze ist ein
bisschen scammy glaube ich zumindest und
warum das so ist das schauen wir uns
jetzt mal an und gehen der Sache auf den
Grund viel Spaß bei dem Video so Leute
ich bin jetzt auf jeden Fall auf der
Seite verlorene pakete.de und die Seite
müssen jetzt erstmal ein bisschen
genauer unter die Lupe nehmen weil ich
das ganze super komisch finde warum das
erkläre ich euch jetzt erstmal so hier
diese ganzen Fotos das ist ja so so
typisch würde ich erstmal aus meinem
Bauchgefühl heraus sagen alles sehr sehr
scammy was mich jetzt erstmal
interessiert wie funktioniert es da
klicken wir drauf okay was sind die
verlorenen Pakete dies ist die Folge der
Störung in der Arbeit von Post Zoll
einer globalen Pandemie und
geschlossenen Grenzen alle Postsendungen
die nicht an den Adressaten zugestellt
werden konnten werden an das
Zentrallager zurückgeschickt von dort
holen wir Sie ab und verkaufen sie so
ein bisschen schmieriges Deutsch wer ist
der Absender solcher Pakete der
ursprüngliche Absender ist gewöhnlich
eine große internationale Website wir
verkaufen hauptsächlich Paket von Ebay
Amazon sixpm das nicht diese Modemarke
yum Alibaba und anderen okay was ist in
den Paketen unbekannt Pakete werden
versiegeln und nicht geöffnet unser
Service öffnet keine Pakete verpackt
oder überprüften Inhalt nicht Pakete
werden wie sehen in der
Originalverpackung an Kunden gesendet
was kann man gewöhnlichen Paketen
erwarten alles von kleinen Kurzwaren
Elektronik was sind kurz waren Kleidung
Medikamente ein bisschen zu Schweizer
Uhren und 3D Druckern ja
bevor ich mich jetzt gleich dazu
entscheide was ich bestellen werde super
dubios sie ist einfach ein Video von mir
ja hey Leute was geht ab und herzlich
über ein Jahr schon altes und dann
gibt's noch andere Videos wo es jetzt
zum Amazon Retouren geht also das hat an
sich gar nichts mit verloren und Paketen
zu tun aber gut hier ist eine
Telefonnummer hinterlegt ich habe schon
ein paar mal versucht die zu erreichen
geht keiner dran lost Post Service über
telegram da antworte mir niemand wenn
mir noch jemand antwortet werdet ihr es
jetzt erfahren
wir haben hier irgendwie so eine
komische Firma Sitze in London ich habe
die bei LinkedIn immer angeschaut da
arbeiten so vier dudes ich weiß nicht ob
ich schon gesagt habe Theorie 1 ist das
ist alles scam und ich werde nichts
erhalten dann hole ich mir aber
logischerweise das Geld wieder und ihr
erfahrt am Ende ob alles scam ist oder
ob da vielleicht doch was dran ist
Theorie Nummer 2 die bekommen eine
Bestellung kaufen irgendein Schrott bei
Alibaba bei wish wo auch immer
Aliexpress geben ist als verlorenes
Paket aus und machen dadurch halt dann
gewinnen eventuell gehe ich ja sogar mit
plus raus ich weiß es gar nicht ich will
jetzt auch nichts vor verurteilen hier
werden schauen aber jetzt heißt es
erstmal stellen ein Paket kaufen ja wir
haben jetzt drei Auswahlmöglichkeiten
und ich dachte mir kommen wenn ich jetzt
schon ja ich bestelle einfach mal das in
der Mitte und wenn es gut ist kann ich
ja noch nachbestellen ich will nicht
direkt das teuerste bestellen in den
Warenkorb eigentlich müsste ich die ja
auch also die können ja nicht einfach
mit meinem Video hier werden das ist so
also das ist eine Frechheit 59 €
runtergesetzt von 79 und Checkout alles
klar dann gebe ich mal meine Daten an
und bestell den Bums okay Leute ich habe
bestellt und jetzt heißt es abwarten und
ich versuche natürlich weiterhin
irgendwen von den Betreibern der Website
zu erreichen okay Leute ich habe mich
also gewagt zu bestellen und mein erster
Gedanke war schon ich habe mich dann
irgendwann altes Video Projekt von mir
mal erinnert wo es so ähnlich war und
das war einfach eine Game Seite und ich
habe nach drei Monaten 200 € oder so
wieder bekommen die ich halt bezahlt
habe aber das Gute ist ja in der
Zwischenzeit ist einiges passiert und
das schauen wir uns jetzt mal an na ja
okay so viel fairerweise jetzt auch
nicht aber fangen wir mal von vorne an
ihr habt ja bereits gesehen auf der
Seite gibt es unten einmal diese
Telefonnummer dort habe ich schon
dreimal versucht anzurufen zu
verschieden diese Uhrzeiten verschiedene
Tage aber es ging halt leider nie mehr
dran also die Nummer ist auch manchmal
abgeschaltet dann kommt man gar nicht
durch dann habe ich es via telegram
versucht das ist schon echt lange her
aber telegram haben sie auch unten
verlinkt und da habe ich einfach mal
hingeschrieben ich habe mittlerweile ein
neues Handy das sieht doch immer mein
altes Handy ja ich habe auf Deutsch
geschrieben weil die Seite halt noch mal
auch auf deutsch ist aber ich bin mir
sicher die Betreiber brechen kein
Deutsch kommen zumindest nicht aus
Deutschland Hallo kann man bei euch
wirklich verlorene Pakete bestellen ja
so sieht das hier aus ist vom 27
September auch jetzt auch noch nicht so
lange her und ja ich kann mich jetzt mit
telegram nicht so super aus aber ich
glaube das wird nicht mal richtig
zugestellt dann habe ich sie glaube ich
auch schon gezeigt mal das Impressum
aufgerufen und bin dort auf die Firma
omnio limited gestoßen die Website von
dieser Firma funktioniert nicht aber ich
habe das LinkedIn Profil gefunden das
hier ist beispielsweise die LinkedIn
Seite von dem Profil und so sehen die
Mitarbeiter aus so wenn ich jetzt drauf
klicke kann ihn nicht kontaktieren ist
halt schwierig da arbeiten wie gesagt
hier Leute dran und ja vielleicht sind
das alles für Scammer wir werden sehen
die letzte Möglichkeit eine E-Mail zu
schreiben Mann
und das habe ich natürlich gemacht
allerdings keine normale E-Mail sondern
ich habe gesagt hey ich bin der Youtuber
ihr benutzt mein Video weil ich wollte
endlich mal eine Antwort haben nehmen
das runter sonst gibt es natürlich Ärger
wobei das mit dem Ärger habe ich erstmal
weggelassen aber sie haben trotzdem
geantwortet ich habe geschrieben hey
please remove my video from your website
dann habe ich die Website verlinkt und
mein Youtube Kanal best Alex bin halt
der beste und die Antwort kam
überraschenderweise ziemlich prompt
hello okay we will do this sorry muss
ich sagen sieht nicht nach einem
seriösen Unternehmen aus die haben keine
Signatur oder sonstiges wer erfahren
auch gar nicht wer überhaupt diese
Nachricht geschrieben hat weil
normalerweise bei solchen Seiten oder so
steht er dann immer liebe Grüße so und
so ne wenn seriös ist und dann hatte ich
anscheinend in der Leitung und habe
direkt mal nachgefragt und ich habe vor
zwei Wochen eine Bestellung gemacht was
passiert damit ist das alles scam und
dann kam auch nee wir checken mal deine
Tracking Nummer und melden uns bald
zurück Tracking Nummer habe ich jetzt
tatsächlich bekommen und es ist etwas
auf dem Weg zu mir sogar soweit ich weiß
drei Sachen und da warte ich jetzt
gerade drauf für euch jetzt aber
natürlich damit weiter wir packen das
aus und ich bin echt mal gespannt weil
vielleicht lohnt sich es am Ende ja doch
let's go okay Leute es ist eine weitere
Woche vergangen und wir haben
tatsächlich Post bekommen muss
allerdings sagen es sieht nicht gut aus
ich habe ja so gesehen drei Pakete
bestellt und drei Pakete sind auch
angekommen und es ist halt einfach so
wie es mir gedacht habe das erste Paket
sieht so aus noch relativ groß es kommt
sogar von einem deutschen Absender das
ist interessant dann haben wir einen
kleines Paket im Absender aus Luxemburg
und das hier ist das dritte Paket
natürlich alles lost packages das ist ja
ganz klar von UPS und so und das wurde
auch aus Deutschland versendet ich muss
erstmal sagen ich fühle mich verarscht
aber ich habe ja auch schon ein bisschen
damit gerechnet okay gut wir schauen
jetzt trotzdem erstmal was drin ist und
dann kann ich ja noch ein bisschen mehr
meckern fangen wir mal nicht mit dem
größten an sondern mit dem Mittel
größten was ist das denn
sieht aus wie eine Tasche oder ist das
vielleicht ein Portemonnaie aber
ziemlich großes Portemonnaie boah ich
habe gar keine Ahnung was das sein soll
kann man vielleicht irgendwo dranhängen
und dann kann man da sowas so eine Art
Briefkasten vielleicht hä ja also ich
habe gar keine Ahnung was das sein soll
hier steht auch leider nichts bei wenn
ihr wisst schreibt man die Kommentare
aber ich würde mal sagen das Ding hatten
Wert von
einem Euro und ich habe ja 59,99 bezahlt
ne dann schauen wir mal hier in das
nächste rein wow
ein Ladekabel so es ist ein Ladekabel
mit Adapter auf usb-cc und was ist das
hier ist das denn ah ich glaube das ist
das vielleicht ein Laser moment mal ja
Leute schon oh nee jetzt meine Hose
gerissen das gibt's doch gar nicht ey
Mist was sind das für eine Qualität und
dann auch noch genau hier an dieser
Stelle aber ich habe das Ding jetzt mal
installiert und ja das ist halt einfach
so eine Art Laser auch super sowas
wollte ich auf jeden Fall schon immer
mal haben der nächste Euro 2 € haben wir
jetzt schon ungefähr verdient naja und
zu guter Letzt haben wir dann noch das
große Paket wo jetzt wahrscheinlich
irgendwas ganz krasses drin ist Alter
hier sind ja noch mal drei Pakete drin
das ist ja nett okay jetzt habe ich mich
kurz gefreut aber das ist halt alles
durch China Ware man ey was ist denn das
eine Klobürste anscheinend ach so ich
glaube ich weiß was das ist das kann man
auf einen Akkubohrer drauf machen und
dann ist es quasi eine Klobürste oder
ein Reinigungsset für die Bohrmaschine
oder halt den Akku Bohrer ja gut sagen
wir mal zwei Euro aber was ich mich auch
ganz ehrlich Frage die wussten ja dass
ich bestellt habe und konnten sich doch
vermutlich auch denken dass ich ein
Video dazu drehen werde und das ganze
Zeug war nämlich mal an noch nicht
verschickt als ich die per Mail
kontaktiert haben hier haben wir
irgendwie so ein talking Headset drin
wieso wenn die eh schon so ein scam
betreiben sind die da nicht wenigstens
bei mir so schlau und schick mir
vernünftig geile Sachen sondern halt
sowas was wahrscheinlich auch den ganzen
anderen Kunden bekommen also überlegt
mal ihr bezahlt dann 39,99 950 99,99 99
unterhaltet im Endeffekt so billig
Schrott für 10% 20% dieses Preises und
da wundert man sich dann einfach immer
wieder warum sowas boah ein Helikopter
warum sowas in Deutschland möglich ist
ja ich meine die Seite heißt ja
verlorene pakete.de und kann anscheinend
legal betrieben werden
fehlt da nicht die Fernbedienung da
fehlt doch eine Fernbedienung
geht das Ding dann an
[Applaus]
wehe du gehst an meine Kamera du scheiße
hä was ist denn jetzt hier los das beste
Geschenk für die Kinder
ohne Fernbedienung und jetzt ist schon
kaputt oder was
[Musik]
das geht an euch von verlorene pakete.de
muss zugeben das weiß natürlich ein
bisschen undankbar irgendwo ist es
trotzdem Spielzeug entschuldige ich mich
für das sollte halt nur so eine kleine
Geste sein weil irgendwo würde ich mich
einfach verarschen ich wurde abgezogen
ja dann kann man auch mal so reagieren
Kamera bestimmt dreckig hier haben wir
das Ding übrigens nur das bei mir diese
kleine Mini Fernbedienung gar nicht
dabei war 5,74 €. ja super okay kleines
Fazit 59,99 habe ich bezahlt 10 € ist
das ganze Zeug hier wert vielleicht das
ist absoluter scam das werde ich noch
mal schreiben wenn man die Seite melden
kann meldet die einfach mal und dann
hoffen wir mal dass da noch nicht viele
Kunden drauf reingefallen sind Leute das
was von mir wir sehen uns nächsten
Sonntag wieder gibt's neues Video und ja
haut rein ciao